plutôt clairsemé les allées de ce centre
commercial soit les achats de la saint
valentin sont déjà faits soient les
festivités du carnaval ont eu raison de
la fête des amoureux
il n'y a pas beaucoup de monde et puis
bon sens nuit un petit peu oui
j'espère ça va venir je constate les
gens couru à vis des puits sont fatigués
donc après bon qui vont venir mais je
sais pas peut-être pour l'instant c'est
encore ce mercredi des cendres ne
manquent pas d'attractivité match de
foot real psg dernier vide et du
mercredi des cendres et saint valentin
alors comment concilier ces trois
événements certains ont trouvé enfin
cavalière on a fait ce soir et je
ressors complètement je me lève
complètement fatigués mais c'est la
saint valentin il faut faire les choses
mieux alors voilà on est là vous avez
trouvé le cadeau ce matin beaucoup de
cadeaux vous ferait quand même le
carnaval aujourd'hui même si le centre
ville de fort de france et ses vendeurs
de fleurs installé sur le trottoir ou au
marché depuis 4 heures ce matin
de l'avis de tous la vente a du mal à
démarrer et l'obligation de laisser
place aux carnavaliers à 13h n'arrange
pas le business c'est un petit peu comme
d'hab ce matin je pense que d'ici là
qu'à la fin ça a pas trop le gêner
vous craignez quand même que la vider de
cet après midi que j'aime mais bon après
on va parce que comme ils vont arriver
cette année c'est pas la bonne époque
par rapport au carnaval par rapport au
carnaval et au carel à partir de demain
c'est le carême oui mais les fleurs
pendant le carême on ne met pas de
fleurs les commerçants du centre ville
de fort de france
eux n'ont pas fait cas des clients
retardataires de la saint-valentin leurs
rideaux sont restés pc